the man who shot metro officer shea
mickellonis also almost two years ago on
the las vegas strip near circus circus
was sentenced today
twenty-one-year-old edgar samaniego will
spend at least 20 years in prison
michilonis who's paralyzed was in the
courtroom eight news now's madison
kimbrough was also there she shares the
family's impact statements and how their
lives have been changed forever
officer mcloughs was only doing his job
there was no reason for this to happen
and he didn't deserve this judge carly
kearney sentencing edgar samaniego the
maximum 20 to 50 years for the shooting
of officer sheamycolonist during a black
lives matter demonstration june 1st of
2020. mikolonis who's in his 30s relies
on a ventilator to talk eat swallow and
breathe his parents and stepfather
taking the stand expressing their
torment while samaniego listened on the
outside we were strong for him
but all of us were broken inside he got
it one shot to change the lives of five
people samaniego read a statement in
court before being sentenced in it he
said that micollonis did not deserve
this and he would trade places with him
if he could patrick neville shea's
stepfather spoke to me after the
sentencing he says it took a lot for
shay to come to this hearing and that it
was his decision to be face to face with
salmoniego he's been waiting for this
for a long time i mean there has to be
some closure to what occurred to him
that night we would like to put this
behind us madison kimbrough live local
now